Thanks. And despite the title, it's actually flip-through mutated and unmutated that we're
going to be talking about today. So this is an update from our study of despetinib. And I'm
going to start with my disclosures and pay special attention to the top line, because in addition to
my academic role at UC San Diego, I'm also the chief medical officer at Aftos Biosciences. I
wrote this protocol, and I am the medical monitor on this study. So let me start by talking about
the despetinib mechanism of action. This is a relatively unique kinase. It has activity against
almost exactly the kinases you would want to hit in a myeloid malignancy, specifically all forms
of FLT3, including the TKD, the FLT3, and the wild-type, SICK, mutant forms of KIT, JAK1, JAK2,
and even downstream of the RASMAT kinase signaling in terms of RSK1 and RSK2 inhibition. But you can
see from the kinome tree, it doesn't hit a lot of the other kinases that are significant in terms
of toxicity and other potential concerns. And that may explain the relatively clean toxicity
profile that despetinib has in the clinic. I want to start with some of the preclinical activity.
These are mouse models of resistance mutations in a FLT3 FLT3 model compared between despetinib and
giltaritinib, showing that despetinib is superior on an equivalent dose basis in terms of prolonging
survival in these animal models, and in terms of the degree of inhibition of the relevant pathways
like phospho-FLT3, phospho-SICK, and phospho-ERG. Looked at another way, we can compare the tumor
volume in these animal models treated with different drugs. The black line is vehicle,
the yellow line is entosputinib, which is a SICK inhibitor.
And then the blue line is giltaritinib by itself. Down there at the bottom is a red line. That's
despetinib as a single agent. And right underneath it is giltaritinib plus entosputinib, where you're
combining FLT3 inhibition and SICK inhibition, suggesting that despetinib can do this as a single
drug, as a multidrug in one pill. We can also combine with venetoclax. If we reduce the dose
of despetinib tenfold to provide some tumor left for venetoclax to kill, you can put the two drugs
together and you can see some synergistic activity. And that's indeed where we're headed with this
clinically. Looked at another way, you can show how venetoclax inhibits BCL2 and could lead to
resistance by upregulation of MCL1. Despetinib sits downstream of the growth factor signaling
pathway, blocking this upregulation of MCL1 in lab models and potentially restoring sensitivity
to venetoclax. And we've also looked at the reverse, where we've made resistance cell lines
to despetinib that we then treat with venetoclax and show that there's actually a hypersensitivity
to venetoclax in that TUS-resistant context.
Again, suggesting that with different mechanisms of resistance, putting these two drugs together
may prevent the emergence of resistance overall. So let me jump now to the clinical data. We first
had experience with despetinib and relapsed refractory AML as a single agent through a dose
escalation and subsequent dose expansion where we treated over 90 patients, only seeing a DLT at the
highest dose level. And then we went on to do a doublet study with venetoclax in the same relapsed
refractory population, giving venetoclax at full doses as there is no significant drug-drug
interaction between these two agents.
So on the left, I'm showing the bone marrow blast reductions of despetinib monotherapy. On the right,
in combination with venetoclax. And you can see at the monotherapy, you see reductions in almost
half of the patients at multiple different dose levels, including patients with those little red
triangles at the top that have been treated with a prior fluid 3 inhibitor. There aren't as many
black triangles, which represent prior venetoclax exposure on the right side of this graph. However,
when you go to the doublet study, you see that many more patients with prior ven exposure were
receiving benefit from this combination.
Again, suggesting that the combination can salvage patients that are unlikely to respond to either
agent alone. If I look at the overall response rates in the monotherapy portion of the study,
it's 29% CRC for all comers that are active dose levels. It compares favorably to what we see in a
much more ven pretreated population in the doublet study with an overall response rate of 25%. Again,
better in the ven naive patients, but still respectable in the patients who have received
prior venetoclax. And again, in a mutation agnostic fashion,
it didn't matter where patients had three mutations or not. And we had several with
really adverse geno genetics in this cohort. Knowing that we can give venetoclax and
tuspetinib together, we went on to describe the Tuscany frontline AML study, putting all three
drugs together in a triplet combination. And here we are giving standard doses of venetoclax and
azacitidine. We didn't have to dose reduce in anticipation of severe myelosuppression because
tuspetinib seems to be less myelosuppressive than other drugs in this class. We are doing a bone
biopsy mid-cycle one. And if patients have cleared their blasts and have cytopenias, we'll
hold venetoclax for that last week of that first cycle, and then allow a treatment-free interval
for count recovery to occur while patients are encouraged to get GCSF. The study criteria are
almost identical to VLAA in terms of the entry criteria. Again, this is a mutation agnostic study,
including most patients who are actually FLT3 wild type in this study and includes patients
with TP53 and complex karyotype. We began at 40 milligrams and have now completed dose escalation,
all the way through 160, and have open cohorts for dose expansion at their highest dose levels.
So this is the study slide as of last week. And you can see that many of these patients are so early
in their course of therapy. And you can see from the middle graph there that many of these include
highly adverse genetics, patients with TP53 mutations, complex karyotypes, RAS mutations,
and patients with many MDS-related changes. But from the middle there, you can also see in green
that many of these patients have achieved
meaningful responses, CRs, CRHs, CRIs, and that many of these are MRD-negative. And I'll go into
the details in just a moment. When we look at safety, the drug has been remarkably safe, both
in the monotherapy and doublet experience, but also now in the triplet frontline setting. The
most frequent adverse events are hematologic toxicity, seen primarily in patients during
the time when they have active leukemia. This is followed by some GI toxicity that is mostly grade
1 and 2, and is partially explained in part by the presence of azacitidine, although we did see some
of this in the monotherapy experience as well. But even the febrile intravenia rate is quite moderate
compared to the ILA-A, where it was about 42%. We're seeing it thus far in 25% of patients.
But overall, we don't see differentiation syndrome, we don't see QTC prolongation,
we don't see significant CPK elevations or significant transaminases, and there doesn't
seem to be a pattern of prolonged mild depression, even at the higher doses for subjects who achieve
a remission. The count recovery has largely occurred before day 42 for almost all patients,
with some patients having residual thrombocytopenia. And again, their low rates of febrile intravenia.
The overall response rate in this Tuskegee study also has been fairly impressive. I'm comparing
it here to the response rates reported for the ILA-A. Similar entry criteria, although the patient
populations are a little bit different now when other studies are competing. For example, we have
very few MPM1 mutant patients. But the CRC response rate has been 77%. The MRD negativity rate is
actually quite high. It's measured by central flow cytometry, down to a rate of 0.1% of leukemic
events. And we're seeing that in 75% of our responders and 62% of our patients, if you include
them all in an intent-to-treat analysis. And these remissions that are MRD-negative are actually
happening earlier than you might expect. I think in the ILA-A, 50% of the MRD-negative remissions
occurred by cycle 4. We're seeing the majority of these by cycle 2. And in summary, we're seeing
responses in FLT3 mutant and FLT3 wild-type patients. Patients with TP53 mutation are
responding, as are patients with RAS mutations, patients with myelodysplastic-related changes and
complex karyotype. We've had patients that have gone on to stem cell transplantation, including
two that have resumed dosing after transplant and another who plans to, and have only seen one death
in cycle 1. And enrollment is ongoing, so some of these responses may mature over time. So to
summarize, TISPET is a focused multi-kinase inhibitor targeting drivers of myeloid malignancy,
significant single-agent activity in relapsed
and refractory AML regardless of mutation status, can be combined with azaven at standard dosing
without prolonged myelosuppression, and preliminary activity in the frontline setting is promising
with high rates of MRD-negative remissions across a broad range of genotypes. The study is ongoing,
and there is a future study plan of TISPETnit+ chemotherapy in younger AML patients that we're
hoping to do with the Myelomatch Consortium beginning later this year. Thank you.